so youtube is hiding this line counts in
an effort to protect content creators
from harassment nbc story
they're making some changes to its
platform in an effort to protect
creators by hiding this line counts on
videos on wednesday the video sharing
service began rolling out a new feature
that keeps the accounts private and only
viewable to the person who uploaded the
video the actual dislike button however
will remain and viewers can still
dislike a video to tune their personal
recommendations but only the talent sees
it the update feature was sparked uh by
an experiment youtube conducted earlier
this year to see whether changes by to
the dislike button could help protect
content creators and harassment dislike
attacks where viewers purposely dislike
a video to drive up the content so now
here's a funny thing that people need to
know about the dislike button do you
know you know this i'm not going to ask
you i'm going to see what tom and tom
are going to say do you know what is the
most disliked video of all time on
youtube something with cats do you know
what it is i'm actually being serious
david do you know you may know it do you
know what the most disliked video of all
time is on youtube i know the most
lacked the most liked oh yeah i do i do
history it's a youtube video it's a
youtube rewind video
yeah so go back tyler go on youtube type
in youtube rewind 2018.
so so the the the person that was
representing youtube when they made this
video oh my god look at that tyler
you are making guy look good 2018 2018.
eight maybe it's the keyboard uh there's
four so check that out
okay we cannot play don't play don't
press on it go to youtube.com go to
youtube.com instead of going that way
you just go to youtube.com
uh click on it you're good okay so on
youtube right there right rewind 2018
rewind 2018 check this out
rewind oh man we cannot press it right
so just click on it and press pause
immediately press pause immediately
pause pause pause okay good so check
this out three million likes 19 million
dislikes and the video to introduce the
dislike button
got 14 000 likes and 147 000 dislikes
people don't like this a lot of people
are saying it's political some are
saying it's youtube some are saying it's
offending people it's hurting people's
feelings i know you think this is a good
idea i do i don't here's the thing i
don't think it's a horrible idea okay
i'm not sure if it's a good idea i don't
think it's a bad idea maybe you guys
will convince me by the way some people
agree with you they say facebook only
has a like button that doesn't have a
dislike button so some people are saying
it from that end don't act like it won't
sway some people when their initial
impression is this video sucks right so
i i don't understand the downside to it
because if you're really interested as a
content creator how many people don't
like your videos you're still going to
know you're going to still have access
to that data are you open to be
convinced like to be to change your mind
no i you i have the most open mind okay
so let me ask alex do you ever go to
when you go to restaurants do you want
to know what review they get on on yelp
um because i'm going to send you some
results
okay now that's a good question okay um
you and sean that's friday night shonda
says babe let's go to a new restaurant
what do you guys do i'm not the guy that
goes to yelp i pretty much know the
people that own the restaurant i'm just
kidding some of us are not celebrities
but i'm talking about no uh dude yes i i
will as a blanket statement i will trust
some of the reviews okay as an i will as
well act right okay so let me ask you
this question now this one you're gonna
change a little bit do you do you look
do you judge movies based on rotten
tomatoes no okay i agree so for me i'm
the same i don't agree with this on
rotten tomatoes but i do follow yelp
right
videos when it's disliked
for me it does a couple different things
as a viewer it gives me like i sit down
it's like i don't know if i want to
watch this or not you know you got seven
different videos you search and you look
it's like this guy because sometimes
what happens with videos people put a
title
that doesn't it's a clickbait and then
you go spend four minutes and they never
explain the video and it's but
if i would have seen the dislike like
ratio and it shows 88 likes and 700
dislikes he's not gonna answer the
question because other people got upset
about it as well so i think the dislike
button helps you save time that's my
opinion if you assume that they're doing
it for the right reasons and i guess my
reason for thinking that i'm against it
or i think it's a good idea not to have
the dislike button is because there are
those groups that go out there and
sabotage
tallies so two sides to it i get both i
think i think there's one aspect that i
can kind of support or understand why
they're doing it uh caleb mentioned in
the chat here and i talked to me
yesterday about it but the last two
years they haven't been like it hasn't
changed the seo on videos so it's not an
indicator of how many like dislikes you
get in the back of the day it used to
kill a video now it doesn't so if it has
a lot of dislikes it's whatever so at
that point the button doesn't really
indicate anything or
improve on the seo so for then for that
matter it's just there to kind of show
it so that aspect of it is kind of
useless at that point
i think there's two things here uh and
the first thing is why is google doing
this they want to prevent dislike
attacks reviewers
you know team up and you get this this
onslaught of people that just want to
attack a video well there's two things
going on first of all tick tock's pam
for creators and tick tock is moving and
so youtube has got to protect its
content first and what it's really
saying is that we don't know how to stop
the dislike attacks the way the dislike
attacks are stopped on yelp glassdoor
you know google reviews is you have to
log in so they want to make sure that
you're a real person you've logged in
you've confirmed the account so you
can't just have a bunch of anonymous
people on yelp destroy a restaurant it
doesn't work or open table so there's
the mechanism that they have there gotta
have an account or you can't slam it
whereas what google is saying gosh if
these dislike attacks happen there's
perfectly good content creators that are
getting hurt here and we're also at a
point where youtube is starting to
increasingly try to figure out with
shorts and things like that how do i
compete with tick tock so i think
there's a bigger thing that's that's
underneath here where google is saying
how do i stop dislike attacks that are
seemingly kind of you know anonymous so
that i can have some integrity to the
count because i do want to know if i go
on yelp and i can't see the negatives
300 positive for a restaurant does not
mean there's not 301 negative i'm like
well that's very neutral because that
restaurant could have been in there for
five years and so the numbers if you
suppress it yeah it's very deceptive i
there's a part of that that you uh uh
make sense on what you're saying with a
like dislike but
i just don't know the more i think about
it you know i want to be able to see
both sides i want to see the like and a
dislike for whatever for many different
reasons
uh you know somebody made a very very
good point here they they speculated
that the reason why they took the
dislike button off is because of adam
because you know adam doesn't like the
dislike button i will tell you by the
way that's why people are saying if adam
is fired or not adam is at another
convention this is this is not a cat
convention adam is in
dallas again by the way is he in dallas
i don't know where he know maybe he's
not in dallas he's somewhere else he's
not at a cat convention uh it's a
different convention he's at he doesn't
want me to reveal it what convention it
is it's very private maybe when he comes
back he'll tell us what the commission
is i mean i know what it is but i don't
guess i don't know if he publicly wants
people to know what convention it is so
we're going to build that little bit up
it's the men against dogs foundation i
see i don't want to say that you you
took it out and he texted him i didn't
want to say it but it is
mad here's here's what i will tell you
here's what i will tell you the one part
that i fully understand so last night
two nights ago two nights ago i'm
talking to tikkun dylan okay
it's sunday night i go upstairs and
talking to tikkun dylan and dylan's got
a voice i really like it when dylan
sings but dylan doesn't want to hear me
when he sings he likes to sing by
himself
and he was singing the other day this
song
hallelujah
hallelujah that whole song right he's
singing it
and i'm listening to him so i go to the
room i put center down and i go to
tikkun then i said tiko dylan
why don't you why don't you want to sing
i don't want to sing daddy i said why
don't i get you this singing coach and
you work with him one-on-one no
why not i have stage fright i said dylan
what do you mean what you have stage
right he says there's such a thing
called stage fright that i said there's
no such a thing as stage fright he says
dad i'm telling you there's such a thing
as stage fright i said who tells you
there's such a thing as stage pride he
says daddy there is stage fright then
tico chimes and tico is like he's right
there is such a terrifying according to
statistics there is that let me teach
you stage fright is people who get on
stage and they're afraid when people
look at him i said tico whoever tells
you they're stage fright they're lying
but daddy i read it in a book that
book's language i'm telling you anyways
long story short we're talking to these
kids
and i'm sitting there going back and
forth with them i said dylan let me ask
you a question i said what's your
favorite song so he says hallelujah by
pen what is pena tonta penta
am i saying it correctly or no
pentatonix something like that is that
the right way to say the band's name
pentatonix i said okay let's listen to
it i pull up the video i said how many
views you think this thing's got
640 million views hallelujah pretty
crazy by the way number like that i said
how many likes you think it's got
he says uh i don't know i said six
million likes he says six million likes
i said how many people you think gave it
a thumbs up okay
thumbs down this is the part where
youtube makes sense he says 74 people so
he thinks only
this is the innocence of a kid because
he thinks how are you not gonna like a
great song like this and i pull up the
number the number is 174 thousand people
put a thumbs up i tell tiko and dylan
174 000. this is their reaction
why would so many people not like it
i don't understand i said tico dylan
here's what you got to understand no
matter what you do you're not going to
please everybody right there's going to
be a lot of people that are not going to
like you so here's a challenge with this
this is the problem i have with this
i've had multiple people that had their
shows on youtube when they came on
valuetainment you know what's the first
thing i tell them don't read the
comments
and if you read the comments don't take
them personal you're a new talent
they're not used to you yet be patient
but i know how hard is it for new talent
to see the commentary that's negative
and you build that up so for new talent
you know dylan just taught you know the
whole thing with stage fright and the
fear so i can see how that can kind of
backfire but it is what it is i'd like
to see the thumbs down uh stay here but
here's one thing i don't think it's
accurate data right i think it can be
skewed so much so i don't think there's
that many benefits from the thumbs up or
thumbs down question are they gonna keep
it as it is right now will that be
locked where you'll see where it is
stuck in time
x or are they going to eliminate it all
together creators going to see it but
the person viewing it's not going to see
it yeah the creator okay we'll see it
but i want i want to see it that's do it
but at that point they should also
delete the remove the likes so you can't
publicly see how many likes there are
because the big thing is also seeing how
long has the video been out what is the
ratio and then seeing okay it seems to
be good it seems to be not so good so if
you're removing one why not just remove
the other and then let the creators see
on the back end can i tell you when we
did this story on vt post last week and
i was thinking about this a little bit
and i have a new philosophy in general
i'm gonna less about big tech
companies unless it really is affecting
my life like a thumbs up or a thumbs
down like this doesn't affect my life
the benefits that the tech companies
bring to me
are so strong that i'm going to hold off
unless they're listening to everything i
say and somebody come and knock on my
door right
so
what you're saying is you're planning on
running for office in california you'd
like their support in the next success
i'm starting with sound like that i like
it
three million donations the reality of
it is we need rejections we need to get
our skin to be thicker and this is
making people softer and i don't support
it for that specific reason so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]